yeah you know live chair
right thank you
uh may i welcome
members of this harbour board
and members of the public who are
watching in
an interesting potential meeting
there is no part two so hopefully
members of the public will be able to
watch the whole thing
we start off with item one apologies for
absence
thank you chair one apology councillor
mcgoss
thank you
item two is the minutes of the meeting
of the 20th of april
i will read from the page numbers at the
bottom
if you have any comments or complaints
shout now
page 3
4
five
six
are we all happy with those minutes well
i'll propose that we accept them as
somebody seconded
uh can we put it to the formal vote
please
sorry thank you chair
councillor bushby
or
cancer christie
or
mr gibbs
to give santo
no
mr hardaycare for
cancer hicks
or
cancer james or
mr paddy or
that's six four chair
thank you
anyone against
any abstentions
one didn't manage it right
item three
the
action
list
um
the only comment i would make to this is
the minute number
unfortunately i don't keep minutes it
would be handy to know
when it was
in future but i hand over to whoever is
dealing with it
miss chair would you like me to just run
through each one of the four actions
because they're all mine anyway
would that be okay yes please okay so
good afternoon everybody uh very quickly
the uh
minute number or the pilot boat minute
number uh this is just a reminder really
on the basis of last year where the
pilot boat was not being used very much
just to keep coming back
to
for us to mark our cars to say is the
pilot boat still being used enough and
the answer of course is that having just
done
two fairly brisk sets of uh
pilot exemption certificate uh runs for
the deo gloria in the last since the
last report um the pilot boat has been
well and truly used so i would suggest i
would uh recommend that that one is um
uh that we tick that one and just keep
that one to review for next time
uh
investigating which should the pilot be
could generate income i think probably
uh it could perhaps be morphed into a
wider let's see if we can't do
ways in which we might use the harbor to
generate more income and perhaps maybe
uh ask whether whether we drop this one
because of course there are a number of
other streams that are looking at in
terms of particularly i'm still working
with cybelko and pike ward in terms of
getting more ships along um but i'm
happy to be advised um either way if we
want to keep coming back to this one
yeah we'll take comments on that
statement any
no
no
fine okay okay move on paul thank you uh
mutual cooperation with overcome i think
we saw in the security meeting the fact
that actually um uh we are doing uh
almost
by bi-monthly or monthly security drills
with africom um
where whereas the uh scope for
cooperation harbour mastering wise is
relatively limited actually our
interaction with the african uh when it
comes to security and using each other
sharing experiences is working really
nicely i think you'd agree with that
kelly
yeah absolutely
thank you um and again i think probably
unless anybody would like us to continue
going back to that one i probably um
recommend that we drop that one but it's
again entirely entirely up to um the
members how they feel
okay drive on the mooring policy
and the mooring policy has been approved
and uh you'll see a bit later on in the
agenda whereby we are actually starting
to um uh implement parts of the morning
policy to actually start um
um getting people to um do what they say
they do that they signed up to do in
their morning policy and that will come
in
my formal report on item eight if that's
okay
okay
any comments from anyone on the action
that's taken
nope so
right we move on public contributions i
don't think there's anyone looking to
speak
no we don't reach here
item five
agreement of agenda i think it's all
part one so we can move on from there
six urgent matters i have none seven
port and harbor accounts
who's taking this one
i always usually ask richard just
standing for this one
no no so chair there are no um updated
accounts from last year quarter four
hasn't been finalized with the finance
team and obviously we're still in
quarter one at the moment
um so the next hoverboard meeting
um
i'll update all members on that
and where we are
but i i'm struggling to
well because of the way local
authorities do their accounts
it's done in the local authority manner
as i read it
the draft out turn
shows a hundred and six thousand profit
but i can't believe
where is the profit figure can somebody
explain it to me
yes sir
jerry if you remember uh the last
harbour board meeting um i explained
that the majority of that come from
staffing um and unfortunately through
the lack of trade in the port
last year
um and obviously the passing of paula
baster
um the post has vacant for quite some
time and there was also a contribution
that had been made to the pension um but
under
ir35
that was returned to the council
so that that is where the bulk of that
saving came from
yeah
if we didn't have that
profit or loss
um the harbour still uh
is a service that costs
um
to to run
um but with the resources that we have
in
place you know we're aiming um to
initially to
make the harbor as i said before and the
pilotage break even and then work
towards
um
you know a profit which is our ultimate
aim it's a business in its own right and
that's how we want to runner
i think paul's report will show the work
that's going on behind the scenes um by
officers
um regarding sebelco
um an additional
business we're trying to generate and
look at different ways
anyone else wishing to query anything on
the accounts chair doug would like to
come in and then tim gibbs
yep
thank you thank you chair um i i would
agree with you i think you know the
accounts are all over the place they
they're certainly not easy and and clear
to read uh i had a circle as a hundred
and six thousand one hundred and fifty
which is made up of the harbor total
ninety six five five two
and the priorities total of nine five
nine eight comes 106 150
but you know they are all over the place
you know there must be an easier format
to follow than this
you know this uh certainly not standard
accountancy practice
sure i think that's the the way the
reports are presented you know there was
always a delay um on receiving invoices
as we report and year-end for next tile
meeting um i'll be able to go through
them in detail last year wasn't it you
know a very
unique year um on on the harbor because
normally it is more straightforward
staffing costs operating costs
supplies sundries
insurance and overheads and back office
is all
listed
um but last year
with what went on with paul
i'm not our paul now but paula buster
did tend to make the skew the figures
somewhat as in a unique year
sorry richard i wasn't so much
questioning the figures you know the
figures are the thing
it's the
you know it's the way that the actual um
document is structured it just doesn't
read you know release you just need an
income and expenditure you know yeah
totals on each of them you know giving
you a balance down the bottom you know
you know but when you read this you've
got you know income total horrible total
expenditure total income total pilot is
total harbor and pilot system there's
too many totals there i want one in the
bottom to see where we are
okay so what what i'll do chair if
that's okay with you i'll i'll speak to
the accountant and the format will
change for next harvard meeting um that
we make it
more straightforward but it can't be too
straightforward because it would just
have an income and an expenditure and a
total at the bottom you'll ask me oh i
got to that yeah so what we'll do is
we'll break it down into almost staffing
operational
um and the categories i've said um
and we'll go from there if that's
alright with you counselor i do like
your right hand column the explanation
of variances but you know i mean yeah
yeah the notes that you put that you're
putting explains where the various
headings are and where the expenditure
was and where the income was that's fine
just the left hand columns thank you
okay
right
anyone else wishing to speak on the
accounts
chair tim gibbswood
right tim yeah i would just confirm i
i've been reading company account my
company's accounts for 40 years and i i
cannot make it the tail of this
it's it's not in a commercial format
that's for sure
it's not i mean i agree the numbers are
it's not the issue it's not the numbers
it's the presentation of numbers
does anyone really understand it
if things go wrong you can pick up where
it is i'm involved in something else
where they've been doing it very simply
and i've had to ask them to go back and
work out why
the figure at the bottom is suddenly
dropped
the
money we were making
and they have to go back all through the
accounts to try and find out which part
of it is cause the the leaking of funds
whereas here it's all fairly well
documented together with richard's
explanation
i think i think we're just over
complicating
i think what's shown there is what's
shown
we need projections we need to know that
projection is gone we know to need to
know what our four year working budget
is and where we are up to date with it
and then you end up with the draft
accounts
i've not got a big problem
it starts off with the problem it's the
local government way
which is different to the real world in
the when they make a profit they show it
in brackets
yeah
yeah
right chair mr putty would like to come
in oh yes mr buddy
yeah okay thank you very much i mean my
my my comment is that we need to make
sure
that we've got enough
the relevant headings to enable us to
analyze the accounts properly
and things like the pilot vote i think
is certainly should have its own heading
because it's an earning
potential but it's also a cost
and the cost the earning potential is
not directly linked to um
to biddeford harbour it's the whole of
the torah gesture
so it's um it's important to make sure
we understand
where the figures are coming and going
yep
anyone else wishing to speak on portland
arbor accounts
no
right
we can move on to item 8
safety management system which i believe
is going to be paul
yes please tom could you or have you
made me a presenter please yeah you
should be able to share okay thank you
uh good afternoon again
uh ladies and gentlemen i'm just gonna
share my screen
and i'm very much hoping that
you should see
uh uh going into business
harbour uh let me show you where
business harbor
and we should get down to
um
and then in here is uh harbour policies
and procedures and
uh in the last couple of days what what
we've done is all 17 sections or
actually knows 15 sections of the um
safety management system have been
posted onto the website oh gosh
hang on a minute
sorry
hang on harbor
policy procedures why is it done that
two seconds
uh it was all going so well wasn't it
where's miss
um
can you hear me
yeah
shouldn't everybody hear me
yep
can you hear me
yeah we can hear you paul
bloody hell
can you hear me yes we can management
system as is now all uh okay thank you
um
uh
okay i'm behind so i'm buffering
so you're hearing me in live at the
moment
we can hear we can't see your screen
anymore you might want to turn off your
video to try and save some bandwidth
there's a cup of cold tea down there for
you let me try and share my screen one
more
time bring it on
i didn't bring it up okay
yeah
mr hardik you probably want to mute you
just press the mute button mr hardaker
um so ladies and gentlemen can you see
the uh um the safety management system
in on the website which has got all of
the sessions of the safety management
system um
this is meant to be a live document or a
live section of the website which is um
so that as amends to that um this
documentation get posted it gets updated
live and this is essentially the shop
window whereby the harbour authority
says and this is common to all harbor
authorities that throughout the land
says uh this is how we intend to run a
harbor and these are the policies that
we intend to do and this is the marine
safety management system um if you've
got a spare half an hour have a look at
it on the website it should be open to
all and if you do have any comments and
when you do spot the inevitable spelling
mistake do please get hold of me or
kelly and we'll update it but um that's
my update on the safety management
system my apologies for a bit of a
bandwidth uh interruption there uh chair
is that is that okay
i've got it any questions
nope
right
smashing i'll go straight into my report
then if you're happy yeah i don't know
so good afternoon uh again gentlemen so
uh a busy quarter lots and lots of
really good stuff happened this quarter
um i'll rattle through it i'll stop each
section uh and ask for comments um
so that uh
i don't get too ahead of myself so
vessel movement wise for biddeford uh no
commercial vessel movement uh more of
that in a moment i'll come back to
cebelko very shortly the only item of
interest is a vessel called the fruitful
harvest came around from falmouth a
couple of weeks ago uh was alongside in
the commercial mooring and has now moved
down to her mooring
just aft of the pacemaker
uh that's the vessel movements for
forbidden on that one paul yeah uh
councillor mcgoff had a go at me at full
council
yep monday night yep
and said he'd been informed that a boat
had been landed on biddeford harbour
from farmers
which wasn't
serviceable wasn't insured wasn't up to
scratch
okay
um is it this fruitful harvest or is it
another uh derek i think he's referring
to the fruitful harvest but the fruitful
harvest has provided proof of insurance
um he made us he's provided
from which is then you can imply or
infer a level of seam um uh sea
worthiness um he came around under his
own steam from um
falmouth uh so it is a seagate no it
might not be the prettiest boats in the
world um but we need to be very careful
just because we don't necessarily like
the look of it um he provided all the
documentation uh and evidence of
uh that we asked him to before he
arrived here
and of course we've got to be very
careful under our duty as an open port
to be able to um ships choose ports
ports don't choose ships and we uh if we
turn a ship away we've got to be very
very careful
for our reasoning to do that um so um
kelly and i were very careful when when
he applied to say and there's a
two-month dialogue i think of of him
saying i'd like to bring my boat to um
to biddeford uh and we said right we
need you to
provide all this documentation she julie
did and put himself alongside now um and
then we put him into a a a permanent
mooring uh after pacemaker so uh
no not foisted
um
and uh
we were very careful to make sure that
we didn't inherit yeah some other
um
vote
we didn't want is that is that a
satisfactory explanation sir
well one must assume it is yes
okay councillor christie would like to
come in
[Music]
um in his report it says uh her
compliance is about the proof of harvest
and her compliance with the stipulations
and the mooring policy will be carefully
monitored
um
[Music]
i hope they are but uh do we now ask for
insurance on these vessels that come in
that
may not be as seaworthy as their owners
think um i do recall that the um ss
fresh spring had to take out quite a
large insurance uh do we ask that of
every boat that comes in now
uh we have done so far um kelly um
so we so the fruit before harvest
because he was um asking for a uh a a a
a full mooring exactly that so there are
some a number of stipulations in the
mooring policy so yes we have asked for
that um
i put the art the
the phrasing carefully monitored only
because i i we were aware through
facebook and a number of other people
there were plenty of people had who had
opinions
about boats coming in and coming back
opinions are one thing but our duty as a
harbor authority are another thing
entirely we need to be very very careful
that we don't allow
uninformed speculation to to guide what
we do we we've got a very
uh firm set of the pulmonary safety code
is very clear about what we can and
can't do when it comes to turning boats
away
chair john puddy would like to come in
yeah
am i okay to come in
yep
yeah i paul i think this is excellent
because you're actually um
practicing what you preach and having
done all that work on the um
the moorings policy it's nice to see
that it's actually being put into
practice
um one thing i did wonder is whether the
vessel was actually put on the main key
as a sort of
um as an interim birth until you'd
assured yourself that everything was in
order
um i mean one of the things of course is
if the vessel will come in here because
of bad weather then she's entitled to a
slot it doesn't mean she can carry on
forever
john it's almost like you've been primed
to say that that's exactly what we did
we put her on there to have a look at
her to make sure knowing full well that
we'd be under fairly close scrutiny for
this um
she's not the prettiest boat in the
world but we we were very we were both
happy that she's um
in the right state and as i say we'll be
watching it very carefully um the
mooring policy and his acceptance of the
morning policy allows us to be
reasonably forthright in enforcing um
compliance and again you'll see a bit
more of this as i go a bit further into
my report
and of course it is some revenue
and date yes indeed um uh it's it's one
thing to say we don't want ugly boats in
our harbor but we do actually want the
the revenue if we can
uh mr cherry happy you're having me to
carry on if everybody else is happy
everyone's finished on that yes
thank you um i will keep popping my
video in and out as my as my video
quality uh works um going on to apple's
all the uh crane barge bristol giants
still alongside a middle dock and she'll
stay there as long as she continues to
pay her bills or indeed or we don't need
the um middle dock
um
i took the uh
dredger ai avocet out on the 12th of
june knowing that i was going to have a
little bit of um
bandwidth issue i would like to try and
share you the video the funky video that
uh we made of her departing did anybody
have a chance to have a look at that i
know you did john but um
i i
we my wife's very good at making these
videos we put a funky soundtrack on it
and um so i won't try and share it
because it inevitably will crash my uh
internet connection but um i will keep
doing that and posting though is on the
website if we can uh just because it
it's it's nice i i haven't got anything
else to say about that other than that
i'll move on from apple door unless
anybody wants to comment
no i appreciated that um video
thank you john paddy would like to make
a comment yeah just a quick a quick
point on appledore particularly middle
dock
um
are we as the harper committee having an
involvement need leveling up fund
submission
by torres district council regarding
middle dock
the the strict answer to that one uh
john f from me is the hot as the harbour
master i've been involved uh but it's
it's well without our out out with our
statutory harbor authority area but as
the marine professionals both kelly and
i have had a an input to that but
because of course it it's good business
and it's good sense uh to do so
and i would say that both the leader and
i are closely involved with middle dark
proposals
fantastic yeah
i'm moving on to yellen then uh dale
gloria came back uh for a two week
dredge campaign um
she as you can see in the report she did
18 acts of policies nine million in an
hour in and out and i had to do a a pec
for a for the new captain and a pc uh
uh renewal for a returning mate she'll
be coming back next year or maybe a bit
earlier i i don't know but uh again a
nice little sort of income for the
harbor authority going forward that's uh
it's on yellend
uh now
now that that man has got his
certificates
does that mean she'll come in and out
without our pilot it means that his his
the pc certificates last for a year so
she comes back
uh
they've previously been quite clever
about this and have made sure they come
back within a year but this last time
they got it horribly wrong and we had
double whacks of of policies but uh so
essentially if he's back before i think
it is the 13th or the 19th of may next
year then his pec will stand but as soon
as it expires and they got a bit stroppy
with me when i insisted on this um said
no sorry your your pc has expired i'm
sorry you need to do another one um but
oh it's only a week out of date
no no those are the rules uh so we
insisted so when he comes back next time
if it's um if it's still in date he'll
be allowed to come straight in
but in the meantime
we get no money from him
where we get we get the conservancy fee
because he comes in gone kelly
uh we would charge um pilotage at a
reduced rate of 25 because they have a
pilot exemption certificate so we do
still get some income from pilotage
thank you kelly
okay i'll move on then if uh if
everybody's happy
yep um going on to sibelco and this is
um um actually sort of breaking news
from this morning as well you can see
what i've written in cebalco we
finally managed to get hold of them
and got spoke to a lady called tracy
who's their uk sales manager and um uh
kelly and i leave fell off our stalls
when she said actually she was expecting
us to shop for because
they'd heard rumors were that we were
selling the crane and shutting the port
and uh and they were going to ask what
it was going to take for us to keep the
paws open for them um we agreed that it
would you know a minimum of six six
boats a year would be nice so anything
more than that and negotiations are
continuing
by uh by strange or happy coincidence
this morning i took a phone call from
pike ward who are the shipping agent who
run who actually booked the boats to
come in to take the clay away um to say
that there's another one in pr in
prospect in the next few weeks uh and to
discuss
uh under-kill clearances and various
other bits and pieces and and they were
reporting uh their conversations with
sebelco and reporting our conversation
with them so finally finally i'm not
going to get too excited about it but it
looks like we might just have a little
bit of traction with uh our our our clay
exporter um i'm not going to get too
excited until we actually see another
boat and then see another one two two
months later but um
it seems that they're actually talking
to us which is nice
um continuing on that you'll see that i
wrote the uh there was a very strong
rumor that cebelko were going out
through even mouth and we're going to
get rid of biddeford and of course that
that is the ukrainian aspect um we can't
take much as i'd love to take an 8 000
ton boat in of an eight you know eight
to ten meter draft um we can't uh
there's you know it's physical physical
possibility for us um and also covered
storage is just not on the cards in the
short term for us anyway so um
that that's gonna happen through
overmouth anyway i suspect that the
costs of road haulage per tonne of clay
might very well become an issue for
cebelco and we are prime candidates to
benefit from that if that makes sense
what's the maximum tonnage we can take
i would say probably about four thousand
tons it's a once we get over about 130
120 meters ships it it all
uh the the the maximum size really it is
a function of the draft it's a function
of the tidal height and it's a function
of the the shape of the hull um but as a
guide anything larger than 120 meters is
starting to get just a bit too big for
us as a guide for you
thank you
chair councillor christie would like to
come in yeah
well can i ask you just touched on the
point about the fuel costs and road
transport
um i assume shipping is going to have
the same problem but um is there any
scope here for
us to get new cargos
uh just on purely on price because up
until now road seems to be cheaper
you're absolutely yes it was and uh and
you'll recall i don't i ca uh i i'd uh
spoken to uk shipping about this uh six
months or so ago of course that was
before the price is what doubled in uh
for rhode haulage um i nudged them last
week to say hey guys you know on exactly
this um and
the answer is or nothing's come back yet
but yes i don't know if any members have
got any sort of connections that might
do that because anything in north devon
we are
prime candidates for doing that if we
can find the right size ships and the
right cargo but um i i don't know who
else to push if anybody's got any
suggestions i'm more than happy to go
and bang on doors
well it used to be dubbing candy council
with salt they haven't been in like they
i i do do we have a contact in devon
county council we could go to
to nudge
this
sean curley can do that um okay
i'll i'll i'll i'll certainly take an
action to go and nudge sean or through
richard and see if we can't um yeah it's
a very good point it is there's a very
real benefit through us you know road
haulage being twice as expensive as it
was
chair councillor christie you'd like to
come back
just follow that up um
at the moment we are inundated in this
area with uh new building developments
and we've got lots of new estates
planned
uh given the rise in cost of building
materials i would've thought developers
would look to shave off costs wherever
they can
we used to import timber on quite a
large scale
i wonder if we could revisit that
uh yes likewise if i i don't know where
to get the contact details for that
though uh council christie or indeed any
any members if we've got um
um
richard i guess that's one for us
yeah
chair um paul obviously
we paul did a pricing schedule back
along for uh the import of steel
um and the issue we found there was
because it was i think it was 1800 tons
i believe was steel that's multi
businesses
all working together and all trying to
and then we looked at the storage
facilities which we could and the
closure of the
um the car park because we'd need that
for a two week period um so it's not so
straightforward but i would definitely
speak to
sean when he gets back from leave and
and we'll look at all options which we
we are trying to do you know there was
years ago fertilizer was imported yeah
um straight on to lorries um we had the
wood export
um
the issue when speaking with nigel and
bob sorry council hicks we we here that
is you know animal feed speaking with a
number of uh the processors
um
but we're limited to where we are for
storage and and secondly any material
like that if it's a windy day
it's uh it's not ideal it's not ideal
but we will keep looking clay is our
main
main
route really for business
uh as well there are other options that
you'll be discussing later for
yes yes chair john puddy would like to
come in
yeah i just wondered um
whether discussions with nigel evans
would be worthwhile
um
simply because they're businessmen and
if they can find a
mutually agreeable way of bringing more
goods into uh northern devon without
road transport i would have thought it
would be quite attractive
i don't know why
yeah
should i come in on that one chair
yeah
if you remember it was one action that
we had uh and the chair and i both went
and saw nigel and sat down and had a
meeting it was some while ago
um to look at what other business could
be you know brought into the park into
the pool
um
but it is somewhat difficult
um
to say the least
well i don't want to keep their lorries
running as long as far as they can of
course they do of course they do
but not not necessarily a reason why we
shouldn't have gone not have a bang on
that a bit because what prices have gone
up in just the two weeks haven't they
last two weeks have gone up again so
maybe it's um
um okay
and the other option is mervyn way
and who's mervyn way
they're the way
the the smallton the haulage contractor
okay
i mean they're all they're bulk and i
believe they do do some harbor work as
well but um
you know i would have thought it's worth
keeping those doors way open because
things are changing daily
yeah
okay
jerry you happy for me to move on yeah
uh members will recall going on to the
london island company uh we had a
good discussion at the last meeting
regarding the uh conservancy rates that
the london london island company were
were paying in the fact that there was
no record
uh in any of the harbour harbor uh
documentation to
uh uh justify or suggest why it was that
the um lundy island company were playing
um significantly below the north what
what they should be paying in the
uh conservancy um rates
in our publish rates uh i spent i sat
down with derek green last week um
i got
as you'd expect and as a business any
businessman would do when presented with
a bill that said we this is what we
think you should be paying he he was he
told me how hard everything life life
was and how they were um
a charity uh and uh we we left with i i
it was a good meeting a a nice uh
a good tempered meeting i left him with
uh with the uh with the challenge to say
okay if you can send me a scale of
charges you think is fair and equitable
um i will then need to discuss it with
my operations manager as in richford
we'll then need to discuss whether you
think it's right and present it to you
as the harbour board to discuss whether
we think it's right for them approval uh
going forward because uh i was very
conscious of the fact that we
the the guidance that came from you as
the members was very very very clear to
say do not
um
do not get under the skin of the other
londy island company because they bring
so much more than just a boat and a
couple of people um notwithstanding that
we've got a scale of charges that we we
we do
and we if we're going to put it in we
need to say
explain or have a record as why we're
not going to do that so um
the conversation is going on
um i
suspect we'll probably end up meeting in
the middle about where it is that we'll
we will agree that what what rate
they'll want to be charged um
i was very clear with them that actually
the rate that they're playing in africa
is significantly more than the one
they're playing in in biddeford um and i
got lots of handwringing and
explanations as to why it's all
frightfully unfair in biddeford
and
i'm sorry i'm being slightly facetious
but um uh he made a very good case he's
a very nice man um i don't want to get i
don't want to
hack him off but i do think we need to
come up with a record and then agree
what we're going to pay going forward
and i suspect it'll be the next meeting
by the time we've got
an agreement to present to you uh
members if that's okay council uh gem
yep fine with me
anyone else wanted to speak
drive on
oh drive on aye sir uh i'm going to go
to i'm going to try and share my screen
again
this time i'm going to try and show you
some lovely pictures of the
um
can
can you see that
no
no
well i'm going to try it one more time
one more time
stand by
can you see the picture of these slipway
it's on its way i think paul
at the moment you're going around in
circles oh my oh you know i can see it
yeah you've got the slip way uh that's
what it used to look like um
and
this is
what
it looks like
now
uh
that's what it looks like where they're
digging it out can you see that
yeah
am i whirling around
yeah we can see l clark's digging it out
yeah thank you very much and uh and then
very last um
uh this is what it looked like when it
finished
um so that's clear uh and they've done
what they did that over a period of day
and a half
um kelly and i are going to monitor this
uh i'm gonna photograph it again in two
weeks time and four weeks time to
monitor the resulting rates and from
there we'll then come up with a um a reg
a periodicity which we go back and uh
and clear the slipway so that we can
then put in the budget and then it
becomes a regular item rather than it
becoming a um ad hoc issue uh my
my thinking is it's likely to be a
clearance every
possibly what
three to four months that we'll need to
do um
it's um
that will come also as a as a part of a
coherent
dredging plan for the births and
possibly elsewhere in the river to keep
the births uh clear so that that's the
slipway clearance
um
comments
okay moving on the oil spill plan and
the incident management exercise the
always plan oil spill plan was uh
formally uh adopted by the mca last week
um and the incident management exercise
was delayed you'll recall that there was
a large fire and a super yacht in
torquay a couple of weekends ago uh
adler and allen the um
our tier two
responder couldn't couldn't
service that and our instant management
exercise so we're doing that again now
on
in july on the 20th of july that's the
or the in the incident management
exercise
uh i think john mr mr pudding yeah okay
sorry i i did have my hand up regarding
the slipway um so um there are two a
couple of questions on the slipway i
imagine the
slipway is concrete right to the bottom
it's the first question is that correct
um
what do what do you mean right to the
bottom
yeah where they've cleared the slip way
it's a concrete track right to the low
water mark
indeed yeah
um okay so
the other question is regarding the
silting i can see the way because i did
go and have a look at it while they were
digging it out
i can see that it's creating a natural
trough
um that will attract silt
and it could be possible to keep that
slipway relatively clear
just by using something like a yard
scraper
on a regular basis at low water just
pushing the silt down because i feel
the problem is not the um
once you've got an inch of silt on the
slipway it becomes unusable
because vehicles can't use it it's very
difficult it's just a case of um as
you're rightly doing keeping monitoring
but maybe look at other ways of keeping
it clearer
and as councillor hicks will know a yard
scraper is a great tool
and
it could do a lot of work very cheaply
the other thing i was going to say is
that is this reflected in the potential
for adding a
trailer charge
for people who are launching at the
slipway in the same way as the trailer
charger apple door
uh two two two items there then uh the
the first one is that uh i'm very open
to any sort of considerations about how
it is that we keep this slip away clear
at the moment it's been
you know it's unfair to say it's been
neglected
there is no formal method or or um or
pre-planned way in which we keep that
clear so we need to come up with a means
of doing that if that means if that's a
yard scraper that does it every two
weeks rather than a dig every three
months then i i i'd be very happy um
could i ask that we
wait and see how quickly that results to
get an idea of the rate first then i'd
be really happy um it sounds like you
and council x both have got some uh
expertise far in excess of my my
knowledge when it comes to clearing
stuff
um what we don't want to do is get you
know uh empty the
uh harbours coffers or for something
that's not used very much so what i do
need to
leaving into your second question is
very yeah absolutely let's generate some
revenue from it but
uh generating revenue from it in a
meaningful way
and i have to be self-declaration
because we can't afford to have
somebody's
little huts charging people it's not
that busy would you agree
yeah
i agree
absolutely
well i think i mean the reality so i i
i'd be really yeah i'd be really happy
to to monitor that and see how we go
[Music]
yeah i mean
it's the same as appledore you know no
matter how busy it is there's a system
and i think once there's a system and
people understand how the system works i
mean at the moment if you go along and
launch your boat what do you do with
your trailer you know what's the sort of
legal setup for parking it do you buy
two tickets
it's it's not difficult because torridge
has got machines both in apple door and
bitter food and they can be set the same
way yeah um we got we've got to be a
little bit careful though sorry to
interrupt you john but you've got to be
a tiny bit careful of where it's it's
apple door is busier
by uh by a significant factor than than
biddeford now that may be a case of the
fact that it's just not suitable for use
at the moment so it's not being used um
so that if we clear it and then people
start using it then maybe that but i i'm
i'm
a little bit cautious about um
committing council resources to
something that's not busy if that makes
sense
yeah it does the 24th of july is the
biddeford water festival i don't know
and already i've been looking at that
slipway and thinking that's going to be
a tremendous asset for that vestal
and we're already looking at um
using the slipway for gigs to provide
the general public with experiences
so i think
immediately we found that ways clear
we started coming up with ideas for it
okay
um i i think i'd like to if if if it's
okay with you jose it is keep um coming
out to this one because it's obviously
going to be something that some we're
going to need to keep working on um and
making sure that we we spend our money
wisely but um um uh but also keep the
slippers there we need to keep slip away
open
tim gibbs and counselor chris would like
to come in
yeah i was i was just thinking though we
to be very careful to make sure that we
we don't spend a lot of money with no
little with little hope of any revenue
coming in correct yeah
as you say i mean
it's not going to attract any anything
much at the moment it's till it's
cleared it's been cleared it'd be
interesting to see what happens
angela christie yes can i ask um i
believe the skirm lodge use it quite a
lot um do we charge them
look
i don't think we charge it we charge
anybody actually to be honest with you
um and again
getting back on go ahead richard sorry
big bum sorry yeah now at the moment we
don't charge for that slipway um and we
haven't done um i'll speak to the car
parking manager um because i'm sure that
if they park they will have to buy two
tickets the same because they're taking
up two parking spaces
um with regard to the kayak racks if you
remember poor air paul of oslo was
looking into that but that now has been
designated for the campervan area but
then saying that there is an area i'm
sure in the short start car park that um
could be utilized um so that's something
that we we can look at going forward
anything to generate income and bring
more
activity to our harbour
i only mentioned that because um sky and
lodge have expanded hugely in the last
couple of weeks haven't they
okay chair um i think i've got a very
firm guidance on that one to say we
let's look at the slipway now we've
cleared it let's use it and see if we
can't um uh one earn a few quid out of
it but also make it a usable asset for
the harbour which um is is
uh very clear to me i'm i'm happy to
move on sarah if you are
very good okay give me the the mooring
policy um i think uh this really is just
me um showing you that um um
uh the mooring policy is very clear
about what what uh what we
uh in order to hold a mooring you've got
to have a boat that's worthwhile
and safe to sit on its mooring this is
the boa pest gadori down on bank end i'm
not going to go into too much detail
sorry can you all see it has it come
through yeah
yes
um
yeah she's free flooding um this is
actually this is taken on the 13th of
june it's a considerable improvement of
where we were just two weeks before that
where she was essentially a rubbish skip
um the owner of this particular vessel
claims
very vigorously that she's seaworthy and
that
uh she should be uh
entitled to a to a birth we are in the
process of uh working this through to
its inevitable conclusion which i
suspect very much will be um
let's um uh if if you can't provide me
with a a viable plan for its return to
see worthiness then it will need to be
removed from the harbor this will be the
first of the next of the stages that we
go through applying the morning policy
fairly and equitably across um the uh
the the entire statutory hardware
authority area and that's all i have to
say about that
chair councillor bush would like to come
in
thank you chair um well
you've asked for views on uh what what
as members we think of this i i think
that's a load of scrap metal personally
i i don't think there's any way in the
world that anyone's ever going to get
that boat um back as a working boat
again in any shape or form there's just
it it will just require a huge amount of
money as uh john puddy will testify
because he's you know heavily involved
in the fresh one this thing is going to
consume huge amounts of money and i
think something like that
alongside the river it doesn't do anyone
any favor especially us um and i'd hate
to think that we're going to attract
more of that type of vessel
the one piece of advice i would give the
harbour master
is to carefully
100 agree with you
nonetheless no
um
because potentially there's litigation
involved here
when we come to kick the man out he'll
object
you get all everything lined up so that
your water tight which he won't be
that some uh guidance is very very
clearly received and i i was just going
to say to council bushby i hundred
percent agree with you the port marine
safety code requires me as the harbour
master to be to follow a process a fair
and reasonable process where i can
demonstrate that i'm using the powers we
could
arbitrarily say no your boat's not see
where they get it out um that's not the
right that's not the fair and
justifiable way of doing it i need to
follow a present principle and you're
absolutely right chair that i need to be
able to show a a track record of being
given every possible opportunity to be
able to uh repair and uh return the boat
to seaworthiness and if it's not we then
uh inevitably we inevitably have to
resort to a legal means but your
guidance is very and clearly firmly
received but i i agree with what you've
said but there needs to be some kind of
time scale involved here because we've
we've all seen books like this you know
moored up for 10 years or more you know
and we end up playing to get rid of them
ourselves he's been given to the end of
july to provide me with a either a a
plan a viable plan for return to see
worldliness or uh uh plan to remove it
chair mr gibbs would like to come in
just just a quick one for paul just
going back what he touched on earlier
with the fruitful harvest do we know why
she's here
that's a very good question do you know
what i i don't i think um uh uh kelly
you might be able to help me because you
you've actually spoken to him but um i
don't i think he just wants to move up
from falmouth it's not you know a
graving or anything else like that i
think he's uh he's moved up here
any any any more
illustration on that kelly
and that is the case um he's been on our
waiting list for um just over a year um
so um we obviously when we had the
silver lining um leave um and also um
the other vessel forgotten the name of
it um leave we obviously had two more
vacancies and we've gone through the
waiting list as per our procedure
okay
um okay chair i'd like i'm happy i'd
like to move on if you're happy sir um
my next my next bullet is the harlem
case and i don't um propose to say
anything more about harlem case other
than what i've written in in my um in my
uh my bit i'm very happy to talk to
members about the open port duty uh uh
but i'll direct you to the portly safety
code um and i think we what we've just
spoken about the beau pescadori and the
demonstration that the harbour the use
of the harbor masters powers must be
reasonable and justifiable and you as my
governing board are the sword of
damocles that hangs above my neck i
could use the powers arbitrarily but i
need to be able to demonstrate to you as
my governing board that i've done that
in a responsible re unjustifiable way
and that probably is about all i'd like
to say about the harlan case um and
would i ask if we could move on
uh no
okay
i want to put you in one piece of very
strong advice here please do
your responsibility
is as you say as an impartial servant of
the court yes and when you are giving
evidence
you will give that impartially
yes
with in fact no responsibility to the
harbour board whatsoever
your role is to assist the court
that is the law
understood chair
uh and is that the the the role the
expert was is it has been very clearly
explained to me and i i'm i'm
comfortable with that it's fortunate
that the guidance
for the the execution of harbour
mastering is is laid out fairly clearly
so i my my room for interpretation even
if i wanted to be anything other than
impartial is fairly is pretty limited
making sure everything is water
a while ago we were just discussing the
role of um
duty holder for the port marine safety
code
and
i don't think we've taken that forward
at all
and that was a we decided that was a
requirement
[Music]
sorry what do you mean
in terms of
it was the duty holder of the person who
effectively supported the harbor master
in that decision-making process
yes if you remember
the harbour board yeah yes
yeah and that that that really is so you
are executing your role as a duty holder
as you do at the here whereby you are
making sure that i am not becoming
a power crazy harbour master or indeed
an ineffectual one and making keeping me
issuing me with exactly as the
chairman's just done very firm and
balanced guidance which is exactly what
the duty holder should do
um so i i i i that sounds a bit trite
but i i've got what i'm just trying to
say is um i'm really comfortable with
the role that the duty what you're doing
is the duty holder and if i felt i
needed some more support i would ask for
it
thank you
um
jerry you're happy for me to move on to
the next one
yep
thank you um appledore um again as i've
said
we've had this discussion at the last
previous two harbour board meetings um
my responsibility as the harbour master
of biddeford structure statutory harbor
or zealous area is very clear um it's
there have been a number of bits and
pieces where people have asked us uh
both me and kelly because
uh for for guidance for
items that are beyond our uh our remit
where it's been appropriate um we've
done so
um i thought it just
um were
sensible to put this in to say okay
people have been asking us for stuff i
put out for example the uh
insto appledore ferry asked for guidance
about what they felt that was the
appropriate use of sound signals uh
going across the river whether it should
be three short blasts or one prolonged
brass i gave them my advice and then uh
we issued a notice to mariners just so
that it's a river-wide clarification um
not strictly our business but it's it's
the right and useful thing to do as a
mariner uh and as a as the local
authority um
and really i'll continue to do that um
provided it doesn't detract from what we
you know are the main job which is
biddeford first um if that makes sense
um
okay hi sure
i shall move on then a biddeford harbor
office
as well as being unpainted and stained
it's also got
rising damp um i don't know whether the
the um uh the council engineers are
going to condemn it or not but certainly
um it's only when you move the uh
the bookcases away from the wall you
realize that actually most of it most of
the walls have got rising damp and
actually
uh the londy lundy side of the office
also as well i genuinely don't know what
to do about that other than to say i
know that the council are aware
and
i thought i'd let you know um i don't
think we're to the point where kelly's
got to wear a master presenter from
preventer from rising damp yet have you
are you kelly
okay
um there's not much more to say than
that but hopefully at some point
go on chair sorry sorry cher
rising dump isn't the problem with it
wearing a mask it's the fungus that
comes with it
um well hopefully we won't get to that
stage
um
squirty fountains slightly irreverent
way of uh disgusting um i i kelly and i
were actually mustering the oil spill
equipment that's held in that uh uh in
that office and in there on the corner
is a bank of very very impressive
looking three-phase machinery there
that's all been in faults and i presume
it's been in fault since 2017 was the
last time anybody looked at it so we've
asked for a company to come down and
give us a quote to see how much it would
cost to repair the the 24 jets um and
see whether it's you know if it's 10 to
28 000 pounds then there's no point
doing it if it's
a you know a comparatively small amount
then i'd like to come back whether it
you know a at a hubba meeting or
extraordinary uh to ask for the money to
spend that but um um i just thought i
would it would be useful to expose this
to say
does the harbor board want squirts he
found his back or is this a red herring
question
personally speaking i know that the
public loved to see it
but i also recall that when it went
wrong it was going to be expensive to
put right counselor christie may well
remember
i do and i was a bit surprised to read
the original manufacturing company
because
i recall we were told they'd gone out of
business this was one of the problems
that we couldn't get the parts
it was going to be very expensive um
i have to add that the original cost was
shared between the town council and the
british trust
and they were put up to mark the queen's
was it diamond jubilee
so
you know there may be bodies we can call
on i suspect it is going to be very
expensive um but
the fountains going off used to
feature quite heavily in uh bidifer's
tourist
material uh as you say people love them
but uh i suspect it is gonna be very
dear but i'll be interested to see what
the cost is
well i think uh kelly kelly got a hold
of them uh where we're used to basically
the contact details on the front of the
three-phase machinery uh got hold of
them and asked them to come down um
do we have a date for them coming kelly
no we don't have a date i'm waiting for
them to confirm that with me
i do have them
just bringing enough electricians down
um next week just to test the power
okay um
but but if i if
as you say it is quite you know you
don't need to go too far into youtube to
find how popular they were but um um
but again be be guided by the board if
we want to go much further than this i'd
be very happy to but um
yeah mr gibbs would like to come in
yeah i would like to actually be present
when if you eventually get the
manufacturer to turn up
just put a bit of practical input into
it
sure yeah i do have a lot of experience
with such equipment
well if you can fix them tim then
i'm very good at looking at them
i might actually drop by one day
kelly who let me in and have a look
please do you'd be more than welcome and
if any any input whatsoever whether it
whether we have to apply for you know
lottery funding or or anything else to
get them fixed if it does end up being
you know a five or six you know
five-figure sum
then
do we know what voltage it is
it's three-phase i think i i think it's
440. i think it is yeah okay okay
uh but you'll be more than welcome to
come and have a look and
poke but um
fine okay
uh moving on then very last uh two last
ones one which will be short ones which
will be a bit longer i suspect um
harbour dredging uh uh the application
went into the mmo for you'll recall mr
mr glover wants to come in and try and
uh do a bit of dredging in the hardware
authority area the application's gone
into the mmo i keep prompting them every
week to say when's my application going
to come through uh or at least that and
i will update you as soon as i can and
we'll get get on with that plan as soon
as i um i've got any feedback from the
mmo that's the um
extracting sand in strategic paths is
when there's a strategic hybrid
authority area and then selling it and
making a bit of money for the harbor
authority
uh lastly uh and apologies that it's
it's a meeting later than it should have
been but uh the harbour users group um
i'm now starting to get to the point
where i'm nearly ready to actually open
the doors and invite members of the
public to come and have a
come and talk
whether it's remotely or by video link
or actually in person um but you'll see
on the on the on the minutes here i've
i've
got a list of uh suggested attendees um
i've no idea whether any or or all of
them will show or send an attendee or
not uh i would be very grateful to hear
your uh comments on whether any of these
are the right people or the wrong people
to come along uh let's do that bit first
so comments on the attendees
on
people i might have missed
um
i would uh suggest as coachella
christie's mentioned skurn lodge were a
big user of the river certainly if i
were you i'd contact skurm lodge yeah
yeah got that one
after all the rumpus last year what
about the jet ski brigade
do we have a is there an association or
a club or something that i can um
getting a single represent a single jet
skier is is always
challenging when they say well i wasn't
asked but is there a jet ski club of of
torridge or something like that that we
might i i couldn't find one online
any ideas
care i have a contact i think it was
mentioned um when the issues were going
on at ecuador so we uh sean doesn't know
if it's the same one
could you zap that through to me richard
i'll include them in the introduction
okay
um
anybody else got any other people i've
missed
john what are you
yeah um i was just thinking of the gig
clubs because um
there's a bit of an apple door and a
torridge gig club so there's three clubs
in the river
and i would have thought it would be
quite good to have the them if
we've got the um the reds and the blues
we should include the um the gigs
uh is that is there a i am keen to keep
it to biddeford if we possibly can john
uh
because again uh i'm mindful of the
danger of extending into appledore and
then inheriting you know uh problems
that we're not ready to deal with um so
i quite can't so there's just a bit of a
good good club is there yep there is a
benefit club okay yeah fine got that one
thank you
councillor christie
yeah you i think you've answered my
question i'm going to put to you um is
there any chance of getting somebody
from the christie estates to come along
and because
i know it's in north devon but
there seems to be more and more boats
ending up on their side of the river
which does affect all the rest of the
users of the estuary of course i know
it's outside of our limits although of
course we do lease the foreshore i think
we do um and it's um uh
having just said let's not include
appledore actually the christus a member
uh uh represented from the christian
states unless members feel that that's
not a good idea probably wouldn't be a
bad one because they are they they are
adjacent to our our
harbor authority area and actually you
absolutely i can get at least a bit of
traction from them then why not
thank you
um
okay thank you that's very really useful
i've got a really a wide
uh a wide selection there okay the the
proposed agenda is a standards harbour
or harbor harbor uses group agenda which
i um i've got you know that there
there'll be all sorts of weird and
wonderful stuff that comes out of this
some of it useful some of it won't be
useful but um um i would be uh possibly
not now but be very happy to receive any
other ideas or thoughts that any of the
members do have about how
things that i might put on there um and
then i'll get uh if everybody's happy
then start thinking about setting a date
uh and inviting people to it um
but grateful for any thoughts or
suggestions on anything else when it
comes to the harbor users group
proper job
okay i think that finishes your report
under item chair sorry
tim gibbs wants to come in as well
just a little bit of experience with
this other places
uh it'll be a big job for the harbour
master if his harbor master is going to
chair this meeting
as he says you get all sorts of weird
and wonderful things thrown at you um it
might it might be an idea to try and get
the group to have a representative that
filters some of this stuff out before it
gets to you
you've you've actually uh neatly
preempted my one of the things that will
come in is uh at least the harbour users
group i normally ask the chair and or
one other to come and sit with me uh
because then it allows a little bit of
um uh backup but thank you yes um uh
chair yes that completes my report thank
you so much for listening to me all
right thank you for a very full report
we appreciate it
right
item 10
communities in place isn't present is he
who's taking this one
um i've got a horrible feeling it might
end up being me again i'm afraid um and
i would um
i'll try and be as quick as i can but
i've got um
i'm gonna share my screen with you and
just show um
so um
uh mr kearney asked uh i proposed this
as a possibility um
for uh a horse box type cafe on the the
working side of the key
um i'm just going to rattle through
these and then i'll shut up finally and
probably um
my thoughts are pro it brings life to a
key which is presently chronically
unused brings income that wasn't there
previously
although i would like to make sure that
that harbour revenue does come into the
harbor account and doesn't go into the
wider council account
might possibly encourage other
businesses
shows that the only answer from us isn't
no
um forces us to look at the actual
utility of that part of the key which is
rather unused underused at the moment
uh
possibly not
another
there there are other areas that we
might put the horse box in
and not necessarily taking those car
parking spaces away but i'd like to
perhaps that's something we can look at
um
the rubbish management is is obviously
always going to be you know
coffee coffee cups and various other
bits we will probably need to write that
into the license the uh
agreement uh tables and chairs um
and any other movements on
a commercial key are gonna need to be
carefully managed while you've got
members of the public walking around on
a working key but it's already a working
key anyway and you've got members of the
public there as it
is
um
i don't
i don't know
uh that the bit i've highlighted on my
screen there i don't know uh
how much the fishermen pay and
what level that is probably something we
need to look at um
and i think probably
um
i i
my personal feeling i know
kelly's not wildly keen i think it's
something that we might uh usefully
investigate a bit further is my thought
as the harbour master um
that's kind of leading off
right well
i was approached by sean on this item
who did explain it a bit to me
and the problem as i see it
is really one of precedent
uh in the past i've been on this council
when numerous other people have wanted
to put hot dog vans and all sorts of
things there
and they've been refused
and secondly your problem is
if you agree to one
you have to agree to everybody who wants
to come there
if you're not careful you just end up
with hot dog
hot dog alley
thirdly
being a council
you're potentially should be going out
to tender on it and giving other people
the opportunity
so i think it's got big potential
problems unfortunately
i threw it open to the meeting
chair mr gibbs and councillor bushby
yeah we we actually had a very similar
discussion at dilbrachum recently in
this very thing and
all the arguments were quite finely
balanced i think the one that threw it
in the end was the litter problem
it was there wasn't uh
there really wasn't any conviction that
despite all the fine things they might
say that they could actually control the
litter situation but i think it's a i
think as the chairman says there are
quite a few issues
that we have to take into consideration
i mean as a matter of principle it's
worth considering anything that will
increase the revenue of the poor that's
the truth
cancer bushby
thank you well
i was approached as a ward member right
at the start a few weeks ago and my
advice to the uh the operators of key22
was obviously to speak to
officers and tauruses and council to see
what they you know what they think uh so
you know the report that sean carney has
done really explains
um exactly what it is actually required
there
um
i'm disappointed that there
already seems to be a certain amount of
negativity here because you know you've
got an area of the key which is
underutilized as it's being said um
there's a there's a few cars parked
there they never pay any parking fees or
anything like that so it's outside of
the main car park
area so to speak and we've got an
opportunity here um
to
you know to gain a bit of revenue well
it's been said several times in various
reports today that we need to maximize
the you know the revenue that we can
earn on on the port and here is an
opportunity where we can earn some money
um
how much that would be i have absolutely
no idea that would have to be negotiated
with the
uh cafe operators but um you know i i
personally don't have a problem with
that and as far as you know
uh going out to tender or or anyone else
operating that you know we've had
um
vans on the key opposite the um
about 30 years up from where this is
proposed uh on a sunday doing uh sunday
carveries etc um that never went out to
tender as far as i'm aware
and we really don't get an awful lot of
this type of application anyway and all
i would suggest is that
you would treat each and every
application on its own merits and if if
it meets the criteria that you wish to
set then it meets it
and you could you could consider that if
it didn't well clearly you know the
answer would be no but you know in this
case i think you've got someone that's
operating a cafe right over there um and
if you put stipulations in that they
have to be responsible for clearing
the site of any drop litter etc etc at
the end of every day that would be i'm
sure something that they would agree to
i'm a board member i'm a member of this
committee i want to see you know every
opportunity given to any of the
businesses in the town so that they know
that the council are actively supporting
them rather than putting any obstacles
in the way
conspiracy
thank you um well
i'm a ward member as well also um
as a member of the british trust i own
the cafe
i also own uh the panna pantry
which got very very upset when p22
erected their canopy illegally of course
and then applied retrospectively for
planning permission um
also a couple of weeks ago costa coffee
had something in jubilee square and i
got
i got lots of complaints about that from
other cafe owners um
it does seem a bit odd just to say you
know one applies and we say yes because
over the years councillor hicks is quite
correct we've had lots and lots of
applications
to go on the key having said that
i've always maintained that we should
remove parking from the key and then we
could use it i'm not sure
about having a cafe on
a key where you know cars do come up and
down and there's a lot of cyclists as
well uh i think we need to look at the
plan as a whole
for re uh for use of the key ron just
let one
business start up there um presumably
they're gonna want tables and chairs or
something i don't know but uh i'd like
to see more detail on this before giving
the go ahead i'm not against it but i'd
like to know more about it and also i'd
like to
well as a british trustee i think i need
to know more about it because i know
what's going to happen with our other
tenants
if i could come back to the chair just
bear in mind that we're talking i think
the application is temporary um and i
think for
52
52 days of the year or something like
that
it's not like it's going to be there
permanently that's what i'm trying to
say
okay
yes
so so
you can see by this report and sean did
say that all the detail isn't there and
that was the whole process of bringing
it to harvard is the fact that to get
members view in principle um if this is
something they would like
to see going forward operationally
there's an awful lot of work
if members think that's the right thing
to go to to get finalized before any any
license is agreed because it is an
operational pork and there's a lot of
risks involved with that
um
the second thing is
forget the company that's there and it's
excellent that they're trying to promote
business within the town and attract
more business but as you've quite
rightly said i think it would be a case
of we've never advertised this type of
thing i know other
members have mentioned that yeah the the
the the sunday roast vehicle comes in
the combine harvester and certain things
but that's only there for a very very
short period of time and not for for a
period of permanent for two months
temporarily for for a longer period of
time so there's an awful lot of work to
go into this and it would have to go out
because we haven't asked if anybody else
would like to provide this or another
type of
vendor would like to go there
so
this is just the beginning really
yeah okay yeah
i'm not some so familiar with biddeford
as
the rest of you but i think it
roughly in line with dougie um
yeah we're looking at in principle and
in principle
let's look at it and see
what's being offered properly
john puddy
thank you very much um
a couple of things here one is that i
think we ought to be looking at
encouraging people to start up
businesses and this is a really good
start-up business and that business
potentially will end up with permanent
premises so i think we mustn't discount
the mobile operators in fact hawking's
ice cream is exactly that and it's a
very substantial local business
i don't feel that the key area where the
fishing boats
is
usefully utilized it's a very large area
of the king virtually totally dedicated
to fishermen
and so there is a there is a potential
for doing something more
and if you look at other places these
pop-up
providers certainly the one on the
boroughs at westwood home is incredibly
successful
and people love it so i think gotta
think you know what do people want what
do actually the people want not the
local businesses because they're there
we've got to think what the public want
what's going to bring people to
biddeford what's going to get them
spending some money
the other thing is that i'm surprised to
know well maybe i'm wrong or maybe
someone's wrong but the parking spaces
along the fisherman's key are actually
free are they free to birth holders or
are they free
they're free just for the lundy island
company john
it's uh it's it's not an entitlement but
they're giving us to the london island
company at the moment
yeah but if so why
why
if if every organization pays the same
level of birthing for their vessel why
is one privileged by having
free birthing so that's another thing we
could be getting revenue from those car
parking spaces and i really think we
ought to
um
so i think those are my points anyway
but i do think we shouldn't just be
giving parking spaces away that could
earn revenue even through
the potential of a temporary operator
hmm
anyone else wishing to speak counselor
push me
yep
i well
i'm gonna propose that we uh in
principle accept this
at face values subject to you know meet
in the necessary conditions that become
so you know consider appropriate
i'll page a second that
um
chet mr chair is the heart master can i
just ask uh i i'm very happy i mean
you saw i've already done a little bit
of work on it i'm very happy to try to
kind of take this forward if you can um
my only question is is the is the
fairness part of the um um
it's it's one applicant for one per one
one site um i the the
the wider ethical issues of whether it
should be offered to everybody and it
put out tender is is well beyond my pay
grade but that's the only bit that made
me feel
mildly uncomfortable other than that it
certainly seems like we need to do some
work on looking at it and taking the
members
recommendation that we should have a
look at it and try and see if we can't
make it work
i can accept i think you're right we
should we should accept the principle of
looking at it carefully
but i i personally think you're very
wrong to go off talking to one
applicant at the moment you you're gonna
lay us open to being fired up from all
sides
sheriff i can just come in here so if we
if kelly and paul start to look at the
operational implications and the
requirements of what would be
needed in the lease agreement i will
speak to
um the legal department
um to to see the the correct process
um obviously the next half award is some
while away so i will email all members
or will will
have an extraordinary meeting or it may
be taken to another committee
um ultimately but i think that's like
you say like paul says the equitable
side of things
um
but we don't want to be you know we
there may be no one come forward then
there might not be an issue with there
may be
other people as coaster christie
quite rightly said regarding the uh
the balcony that went on with the
veranda um there was a lot of issues for
for
for members of biddeford at that time
so i will take it to legal uh and paul
and kelly look into the operational side
of things and what's required
and technically uh the estates people
ought to be looking at rental values etc
yeah that'll that'll all be discussed
part of the uh whether it's a lease or a
license
that will all have to be agreed in in in
whatever
way we go forward
it's the only thing that comes to my
mind is that
it may be that we can take it to cnr as
a quicker way of doing that
yeah
i think that's right but sean carney was
of the opinion obviously quite correctly
that you know as a harbor board
or
we had to be taken into consideration
obviously in the first instance if we
you know if we'd had really specific
reason to say absolutely no way we've
got other plans for it or something like
that then it's a no-no but if we're
happy in principle that it goes to cnr
that you know that that's fine because
if that speeds it up because clearly the
you know the applicants
want to take advantage of the summer
season so they don't want it right and
on and on yeah
that's where my mind was running so
as i said our proposal
when it comes to james seconded up
yeah councillor christie and john puddy
would like to come in
thanks for chris oh okay i'd like to
hear what the proposal was again that we
are going to look at this
yeah i think council bushby made the
point that there does need to be some
fast tracking here because i suspect
they don't want to miss the summer trade
yeah um so we do need to go
fairly quickly on this
cnr is in a month's time isn't it
okay that's
25th
reasonable
july is the next one chair
well
let's see how
yeah
just have an extraordinary hard evolved
meeting
the chair of thank just coming it sounds
very much well you if you take the vote
that the you know and from the
operational side from paul is that we
have no objections to
um a pop-up trailer or a pop-up facility
on that area um subject to that it meets
all the criteria that we need it will be
then down to the estates team
um
to go into the details of the lease and
what's required that's not for us so the
harbour board we don't have to have
another harbour board meeting because in
principle we agree
that that is that is fine um we'll have
to discuss with the london company
because they are allocated
unlike ill for coomb in bitterford they
are allocated three parking spaces um
so that that will have to be discussed
as well um
but as long as paul in principle is
happy with the lease that comes through
then that can be done very very quickly
thank
you okay well just to formalize can we
put it to the vote please sure i think
uh mr hardik would like to come in sorry
yeah
so uh could i just be an excuse i've got
to take mrs hardaker to the
doctors uh
um thank everybody for
all their uh input and to sandra
uh in particular for sending kirsty
around to help me
uh
actually get to a meeting instead of
all the traumas i had at the last
meeting thank you very much everybody
thank you you know
bye
john paulie
i'm sorry um it's just a question for
paul
um maybe i misheard you paul but you
said you weren't aware of what the
charges were for the fishermen
uh we need to we need to investigate it
to see whether actually it that how much
they're um and where much how much the
charges are but i don't know how much
the the the harbour ball makes it's a
point to say actually
this this key is not being used for very
much at all there's a couple of
fishermen who wander around some of them
who were still chasing a bill from one
and actually the opportunity to make
some money out of a bustling busy local
business that's actually trying to do
something positive strikes me as being a
fairly good thing to do
thank you
i think we're going to vote when we
yeah
right
those in favor of the proposal as put
forward
by councillor bush being seconded by
councillor james
okay sandra will take a recorded vote
thank you chair
councillor bushby
[Music]
abstaining
cancer james
or
mr puddy
thank you that's five four and one
abstention chair
thank you
um
now i believe that brings all
future meetings
talking of the 20th of october any
problems with that
so we'll assume that's what it's going
to be at this stage you can diary it up
any other business
yeah mr putty goes hand raised
um
i just wanted to ask is the island of
israel
walk
um managed by the harbour board or
torres district council
are you on actually about the the the
railings and the pathway as in for
cleanliness and maintenance
yeah i'm actually mentioning just that
um richard because
um
the fresh spring team have undertaken to
start removing weeds alongside the ship
which has really improved the appearance
but looking all the way along land a
visual walk it's really actually in
pretty poor order and one of the things
that was noticed when the team were
clearing was that the
growth along the front of the
um the the the key front there is
actually lifting the paving slabs which
is
going to cause much more of a problem
later on
um and at the corner
just to the stern of fresh spring the
um the retaining wall there is actually
collapsing which is making that
particular part of the area very
dangerous
so it's really i didn't just wanted to
know who was responsible and what
happened
the core of the wall is very dangerous
have you reported that to anybody
it was reported
when in 2016
right okay well that was the obviously
the upkeep of the structural element of
the key is the estates team um and what
we will do is i will send a message for
someone to come and take a look as for
the detritus and weeds then that's
something that my team here will look at
along with
the rest of torridge
okay
can i say one more thing please check
um the other thing is going back to the
water festival wall
the rotary club of biddeford have
actually been talking to the fire
brigade regarding
washing the steps down and i don't i
just
offered them a caution to say well
actually don't
take on something that is potentially
the port authority's responsibility
without talking to the port authority
and so um
i'm hoping that the rotary club of
biddeford will actually be talking to
you paul regarding both the um cleaning
of the steps and the positioning of the
craig during the water festival
uh yes i sincerely hope they will do too
because otherwise well i should stamp my
little feet
um because it it's it's our harbor it's
not the rotary club so the racial club
will ask us where they'd like us to do
it and we'll we'll tell them but fine
uh thank you john for that i'm grateful
if you could direct them in our
direction we'll help them and make it
happen but um
fine
okay any other business
then i'm going to declare the meeting
closed